tis the season for all kinds of fun
stuff included footy pajamas it is the
PJ 5K it's returning to the Las Vegas
Motor Speedway proceeds support local
children in need John Bentham you are
very familiar to us you're the producer
of glittering lights which is part of
the speedway Charities because you guys
donate to but you're also on the board
so we're going to talk about that as
well as one of the participants Katarina
bussman and you've done this for several
years yes so let's get into the meat of
it
um when is it so the PJ 5K is this
Sunday okay uh people can start showing
up at three o'clock you can still
register at online at Speedway
Children's Charities dot org great or
you can come right to the event you mean
p.m 3 P.M and you can come in your
onesies or your pajamas or just some
casual comfy clothes because you can
walk or uh run through glittering lights
excellent and so you get to see
glittering lights before kind of you
know it's kind of like special it is
it's actually the only time you can walk
or run through glittering lights and
that's kind of cool because you're out
of the car you're in the elements you're
kind of you know Sherry's been bringing
this great winter weather for us so we
get to continue that Outdoors so it's
gonna be it's gonna be a great night
okay so uh so there's that Katarina you
guys have done this you and your family
yeah and what is this for you I mean
it's kind of like the beginning of the
holidays but you're getting back really
it's the kickoff to the holiday season
we get to dress up our dogs in their
best pajamas every year gets a little
bit of a family competition and we all
can get together and then afterwards
have hot chocolate and really start
planning all of our holiday meals so
this is the kickoff I love it and and
you've got the Grinch pajamas on today
kind of the theme I'm going with this
year okay we'll see if it changes at all
before Sunday oh you got a little time I
have a few more days nothing better than
wearing pajamas and I love seeing all
these pictures here so much fun because
now we know it's dark enough at 4 or 4
30 p.m where you can see the lights
let's talk about Children's Charities uh
Speedway Charities what it does and how
it works so Speedway Children's
Charities is our board we raise money
all year long and then through a grant
process we give it away to local
children's in need so a couple
requirements uh is that you are in Clark
County okay and you service children and
then 100 of the funds that we give to
you through the grant process are used
towards those children's programming so
it's it's really great um between
glittering lights the drive-through and
the PJ 5K we contribute the most to uh
Speedway Children's Charities incredible
uh and you know every year we donate
between 350 to 500 000 towards local
children's programming and it's small
Charities up to bigger Charities like
candlelighters and Ronald McDonald house
but yeah the smaller ones that you know
provide glasses eyeglasses for kids that
don't can't buy eyeglasses and need to
see that's a great great organization a
fun event to get out there bring the
family like Katarina enjoy the season
guys thank you so much for coming on the
show this morning it's still time we can
still sign up right you can absolutely
sign up you can actually show up right
uh Sunday we the race starts promptly at
4 30 because we've got to get through so
that we can open up for the the uh for
the driver on the drivers that's right
and Sunday is actually World kindness
day so if you actually then drive
through on Sunday you get a free pass it
along ticket compliments of one of our
partners Anthem injury laws look at all
this wonderful stuff and then of course
as I send it over to Sherry Sherry's
going to have great weather for all of
that fun oh we want to see we want to
did you put your hood on we want to see
John in the hood where's your reindeer
listen there's only there's there's only
one person that could make it back to
John there let's see that we got to see
the reindeer
well you got the perfect